I'm dr. Armand Dorian the chief medical
officer at USC Verdugo Hills Hospital
I'm also an ER doctor and unfortunately
I see a lot of people overdosing and I
know a lot about those drugs today we're
gonna be discussing a few popular songs
and their reference to drug use I'm
gonna actually break down those drugs
and what they do to your body let's
begin now I hit that epi yo with duffles
in my hands I did have a Z 13 I was
chillin heavy out like a light okay so
what is Drake saying there first of all
great song I just don't like the message
he says I did half as an 13 hours till
Ellen had me out like a light a so xanax
is a medication that was created for
panic attacks it also helps with sleep
and it looks like in reference to that
Drake was taking it for a flight so he
could sleep what xanax also does is it
slows your heart rate down slows your
breathing down so if you take too much
you'll actually stop breathing you'll
not be able to protect your airway and
you can die this next one is by Eric
Clapton called cocaine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay eric clapton cocaine he says if you
got bad news you want to kick the blues
cocaine when your day is done and you
want to write on cocaine it actually
makes sense because when you feel like
your day is done you feel like you're
exhausted if you take cocaine it just
revs you up cocaine makes you feel like
you're superhuman makes you like a
Superman we actually use cocaine in the
hospital and ironically we use it in the
nose we use it for when your nose bleeds
we put a little bit of cocaine in there
to squeeze down those blood vessels to
stop the bleeding but we don't give you
the amounts that actually cause you to
have the high what happens when you take
cocaine you feel like you're Superman
you feel like you could just run through
a wall you feel like you can lift the
car and the problem with that is it
starts burning your body to the ground
your heart actually can't take that
speed can't take that effect of cocaine
and you end up having a heart attack and
dying the next one is better now by post
Malone
[Applause]
[Music]
drinking and I'm trying to forget all
right so what is post Malone saying to
us here and better now he said and I'm
rollin rollin rollin rollin with my
brothers like it's Jonah's Jonah's
drinking Henny and I'm trying to forget
so drinking Henny is alcohol and alcohol
we know is a massive problem in society
we see people drinking all the time
actually small amounts in the legal
limit is actually good for you there's a
lot of studies that show that it's okay
but here's the problem when you start
drinking too much alcohol it starts
pickling your brain and alcohol so it
starts making you be very sluggish and
unable to react to actual life's
problems then you add something that
makes it a lot worse you add Molly you
add benzos which are xanax those drugs
it's like basically having a campfire
and then dropping a grenade at it boom
it's a big explosion in your body your
body can't react to it can't adapt to it
and you end up dying so this is not a
joke this is not something to say or
sing about that you're gonna be better
now you're definitely gonna be worse now
okay the next song is wake up in the sky
by gucci mane correct black and bruno
mars it's my life
[Music]
okay wake up in the sky gucci mane Bruno
Mars and Kodak black I'm on adderall I'd
be smelling high-tech when I piss like
it's basketball I dropped 50 pointer on
my wrist there's no question you're not
gonna be dropping 50 pointers if you're
on high tech high tech is a cough syrup
so that's what we use it for we
prescribe it for people to take when
they have pain and they have multiple
persistent coughs unfortunately the
medications inside that cough syrup
high-tech is actually very similar to
heroin it's it's an opioid which we know
are you hear on the news it's one of the
main causes of death are overdoses now
so what it does to your body is it it
puts you in a really slow state then you
add adderall which is meth which
initially supposed to shoot you up but
then it makes you crash you add the
crash to that low state your heart slows
down your breathing slows down and
you're barely alive kind of like a slug
next we're listening to Danny Brown died
like a rockstar so let's break down
Danny Brown died like a rockstar
he says stiffen at all off the counter
in my kitchen tripping off the that had
Brian Wilson flip in then he says a shot
of hennessey spiked that with some Molly
tell mommy I'm sorry god bless my soul
so Danny Brown's mentioning sniffing
adderall which Rockets your brain super
fast super high you're snorting it so
it's getting to your bloodstream
immediately then you're adding Hennessy
which is alcohol to kind of slow you
down and it kind of pickles your brain
in this state where you can't make wise
decisions and then finally you add the
drug Molly which is basically who knows
what's gonna do it can do anything at
any time those are basically the three
musketeers of death let's listen to the
next song by Peter Tosh legalize it
[Music]
so Peter Tosh legalize it doctors smoke
it nurses smoke it judges smoke it even
the lawyer do Peter Tosh was ahead of
his time
we are legalizing it marijuana is really
not that bad when we look at the big
spectrum of drugs some physicians
actually do smoke it there are some
medicinal qualities of it when it comes
to nausea but too much of it actually
can cause vomiting nobody's really
overdosed on marijuana but overall it
slows you down too much and you can't be
an active player in society you're just
not going to be at your hundred-percent
best I'm telling you I'm not preaching
to you drugs are not good make the
decision to stay away from
[Music]
you